المصفوفة، هكذا
يصف أحد الركاب رحلة طيران Allegiant المتجهة إلى فلوريدا
بعد أن شهدت
اضطرابات شديدة لدرجة أن المضيفات
أرسلنها للطيران في الهواء،
يُظهر موقع FlightAware أن طائرة إيرباص A320 هبطت بحوالي
8000 قدم في أقل من دقيقتين
للدفعة الأولى من الطائرة.  كان الاضطراب الذي ضربناه
شديدًا لدرجة أنها هبطت على
أرضية الكابينة وقال لها ابني
هل أنت بخير وبمجرد أن قال أننا
وصلنا إلى الجيب الثاني من الاضطراب
وذلك عندما انتقلت حرفيًا من
أرضية الكابينة إلى  سقف
الطائرة إنه أمر سريالي، أنت تنظر إلى
هذا ثم تسقط ولا يمكنك
حتى وصف الرعب، لقد بدأت للتو في
الصلاة وتلك المضيفة أعرف أنها
كسرت كاحلها، كان الأمر فظيعًا ولكن
أعني أنني أعرف أنها  إنها بخير لأنها
تمكنت من الحصول على الرعاية الطبية عند الهبوط